عامل توصيل طلبات دليفري مسن بمحافظه
الاسكندريه يحصل تعاطف المصريين بعد ان
ضجت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بقصته اصبح
عامل ادلفري باحد المطاعم يبلغ من العمر
65 عاما حديثا السوشيال ميديا خاصه بعد ان
رفض الزبون طلبه وشن حمله لطرده ليكسب
بعدها تعاطف الملايين
[موسيقى]
شو اللي حصل وشو الي اغضب الزبون تحديدا
حديثنا انت اكثر
واحده ونصف بالليل
لو سمحت لو سمحت حضرتك
[موسيقى]
تعال خذ خذ
قدام الباب
ورنيت عليه وهو مش عايز ياخذ الاوردر قال
لي طب تعال من الاردن
خصموا علي الاوردر 160 جنيه
قال لي امشي ثاني يوم راح بيتصل بي قال لي
تعال بعد ما قال لي تعال رجعني الشغل
ارشال مني الخاصه انت طبعا توصل
في تلاسم بينكم في التليفون قبل ما توصل
له الطلبيه ليش زعل ما فتح الباب
طلعت له فوق طلعت له وخبطت عليه يعني انا
خلاص خلصت معه المكالمه رحت طالع على طول
طلعت على طول لغايه باب الشقه ما رضاش
ياخذ الاوردر
مطعم بتصل بي قال لي تعال في الاردن ثاني
يوم راح مرجعني على طول المطعم رجعني ثاني
لما هو راجل صاحب الاوردر صاحب الاوردر
همم قدم شكوى هو اللي مقدم حتى شكوى فربنا
سبحانه وتعالى
والحمد لله رب العالمين انا باشكر كل واحد
وكل شاب وكل بنت
الحمد لله يعني
انا راجل عندي 65 سنه والله طلع له طلع له
الاردن واسمع الكلام لما رجعت المطعم
بيقول له بيقول له انا ما كنتش هتاخذه
قدام الباب هيطلع هاضربه ثاني يوم راح
مصورني وحطوني على الجروب
[موسيقى]